i can't imagine what it's been like for
the two of you
having knowing how good the movie is and
having to wait years for audiences to
see it so true i mean we love the movie
but you never know what an audience is
going to do when they watch it and very
fortunately for us
so far every audience has really
embraced the movie the way we thought it
would for for soon to be fans of the
movie i am curious what shot or sequence
was the one that both of you said we are
never going to be able to pull this off
well i think i i just about everything
in the air scares me after death but it
didn't scare tom or joe they figured out
a way to do it joe found a way to get
six cameras inside the cockpit of an
f-18 and
they trained the actors for three months
in various aircrafts so they could
withstand the g-forces first time we did
it every actor except for tom threw up
couldn't use one frame of footage except
for the stuff on tom
so it was very difficult the first time
and joe and tom figured out a way to get
it right yeah i mean obviously the the
aerial was a was a huge part of it jerry
said at the beginning he's like these
other actors are never going to make it
i'm just telling you you know we've been
through this before
and
tom was you know determined that it was
all about preparation and he was right
so starting them in the cessna going to
the aerobatics then to the l-39
that sort of training got them to the
point where they all felt confident and
you know it's not to say they didn't get
sick up there but
um
you know you just can't fake what what
we were you know going for it you just
you know it's you can't do that on a
sound stage
one g-force is your own body weight so
they were pulling five six times their
body weight can you imagine that
pressing down on you and trying to act
and trying to turn on the cameras at the
same time and remember you're making a
movie and why you're getting sick at the
same time so it was really rude on our
actors they were soaking wet when they
came down off those off those flights
yeah things i could never do ever not
not even in a million years um i think
tom cruise is a true movie star he is
the goat of action there's no one like
him for both of you can you just talk a
little bit about working with tom and
just the things that like he does that
no one else does in terms of his
preparation or the way he treats other
people or just anything you want to you
know say well it's not it's not just
about his character i mean obviously
he's got a really
strong grasp and perspective on on
maverick certainly uh it being one of
the most iconic characters of all time
but
he's made 50 movies now produced a lot
of them and understands
how to make a movie understands every
department obviously with this one being
a licensed pilot
an aerobatic pilot he had very specific
knowledge about
um how to prepare for it so
uh you know working with tom it's a
partnership um and he's in it every
single day
uh
with us
figuring it out problem solving figuring
out where the challenge is going to be
cautioning me you know on mistakes he's
made before
um it's it's just
there's nothing like it um and uh it's
it's an adventure every single time you
know i think tom
like joe said has made so many movies
and he's worked with some of the best
people in the business great directors
great writers
terrific actors and he's he's a sponge
he absorbs it all he looks forward to
going to work in the morning he loves
what he does that's his life he loves
making movies and it's so great to have
somebody around you that's enthusiastic
wants to do the best it's a great
partner to add never do better he's one
of the most talented actors if not the
most talented actors in our business
yeah um i again i just want to say
congrats and i loved seeing the simpson
brookheimer logo at the beginning of the
movie made me very happy um thank you
both so much for your time thanks steve
thanks steve